visière tir porte ou support pour des
écrans de protection en plexiglas les
différentes productions de lino blague
d'explo depuis le début du confinement
grâce à son imprimante 3d le site de
montigny le bretonneux a participé à un
réseau d'ateliers de fabrication
objectif répondre aux besoins des
personnes en première ligne dans la
région c'est parti d'un mouvement très
large en france à partir de là en fait
on à 110,9 lab comme on a une imprimante
3d on a voulu participer
on s'est rapprochés de notre direction
en interne auprès des collaborateurs qui
étaient tous qui justement sont restées
en activité pour faire ces éléments
pourrait d autres projets l'utilisation
de l'intelligence artificielle pour
étudier des mutations du colis de 10,9
dans plusieurs pays à partir de données
publiques de savoir est-ce qu'on peut
par exemple associé à une souche
particulière avec la mortalité qui est
observé dans les régions où les pays
dans lesquels elle cj après le second
enjeu c'est de déterminer si le virus a
suffisamment muté pour qu'un vaccin
universel ne sera pas suffisant a donc
pour le moment c'est pas le cas donc
c'est plutôt rassurant répondre à cette
crise sanitaire synonyme d'innovation
des innovations au niveau technologique
mais aussi dans la manière d'innover une
activité entre les collaborateurs du
groupe ouverte vers d'autres partenaires
extérieurs on a appris que l'on pouvait
dépasser des processus y aller vite sur
les choses qui ont du sens on a appris
que individuellement les collaborateurs
avait plein de ressources plein d'idées
plein de propositions et qu'il pouvait
qu on n'était pas les seul tenant du
savoir et que c'est en échangeant étant
beaucoup plus ouvert que finalement les
bonnes idées arrivent comme beaucoup
d'entreprises explique s'est aussi
adaptée au contexte la majorité des
salariés ont poursuivi leur activité en
télétravail